hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be looking at some in-game
tactics this specifically is from the
cevedro position very famous position
in chess and at the end of this video i
don't necessarily want you to memorize
all the moves i more want you to
understand the concepts that you should
be thinking about
as you approach the end game in this
position right here it's white's move
and if you've never seen this before the
first thing you may look at
is that white currently has pawn and a
king
so currently behind as far as material
but two squares away from promoting
the pawn here to c8 black is up
material currently with the rook here
but does have his work cut out for him
as he tries to stop this pawn
pushing forward here to c8 now
spoiler alert white can actually win if
played correctly but there's a lot that
goes into playing correctly
when you do have a past pawn here the
first thing you need to always be
looking to do is can you push
that pawn in this case the first move
from white does need to be
c7 and now things get a little trickier
for
black black really wants to stop the
pawn
from coming here to c8 but we can
clearly see that it cannot come here to
d8 because it could just be captured
here by the pawn
and it can't come here to c5 because
they would just be captured by
the king so black's other alternative is
just to start
checking the king right away and so the
first move might be
rook to d6 now a lot of players in this
position while we already said that
white
wins this game if played correctly a lot
of players would look at this and say i
need to attack
the rook right away
and what you really need to be thinking
about in games is what opportunities
do you have long term and how can i
mitigate all the risk that my opponent
is threatening against me because if you
play
king 2 c5 this is not the best move and
white
is going to end up either drawing the
game or potentially losing if white does
not play correctly from here
because after king tube c5
black has the move rook to d2
you can probably already see with the
skewer coming if the pawn
now pushes forward here to c8
well then white completely loses because
rook to c2
and after the king moves then the rook's
gonna capture right here on
c8 if white does not push forward
maybe they play something else maybe
instead they play
king 2 b5
okay well now just rook to b2 here
they can chase the the king around the
board if the king ever comes down
to this fourth rank here then
the rook can just come to c2 and white's
gonna lose again there's no protection
on this pawn here on c7
and even if the king were to let's say
come back to c6
and rook to c2 king up here to
b7 and it chases it here where now it's
defended
anytime the king moves then the rook can
just come to d2 and chase it around the
board
there's no way that white's ever going
to be able to push that pawn
any higher up the board so
we see that d6 and c5 here
is not going to be the best option the
best option for
white is first going to be to play king
2 b5
now let's take a look at why this is
important still blocking off
the critical squares can't come to c6
or d8 those are the main squares that
black can immediately go to
to threaten the white pawn pushing
hereward to
c8 and now the rook cannot come down to
d2 with the threat of c2 because now
white can just push forward here with
c8 promoting to a queen and white should
easily win
a queen versus a rook in game
so instead black is really forced to
play rook
to d5 continuing to check because if the
king moves
here from a1 similar to his before
after the pawn pushes here to c7 if
black does not continue to put pressure
on this white king
king here to a2 to b2 to b1
all of these are just going to result in
the pawn pushing forward here to c8
and getting that queen white is going to
win
the game so after c7
rook to d6 check king to b5 so it's not
on the same file as the pawn very
important
rook to d5 white has to continue the
same theme cannot come to
c4 because the rook can now come down to
d1 and same as before
the next move is going to be rook to c1
skewering this king and
pawn potentially up here on c8 if it
pushes
forward and promotes here so that's not
gonna work for white
needs to keep it off the same file here
so white can play king to
b4 now
black has to continue the same theme as
before and play
rook to d4 while this king is not on the
same file as the pawn it's doing a good
job of protecting
this file from the rook over coming to
the c file
to attack this pawn here on c7
so after this check right here
continue down with king to b3 and after
rook to d3
now the first time only can white play
the move
king to c2
and why is that you can probably see
that black would really like to come
down to
d1 so you can swing over to the c file
but the king here on c2 is protecting
that
now a lot of players playing as black in
all honesty would resign
in this position because they recognize
there's nothing that they can do
to stop the pawn pushing here to c8 but
black actually does have have a very
creative move
while white still has a better move on
top of that
black has a really interesting way to
attack this
and that is to play rook to d4
and the reason that's such a good move
is white may look at this and say okay
well i'm just going to go ahead and play
pawn 2 c8 get my queen
and then black and play the move rook 2
c4 check forking the queen here on
c8 white is forced to take with the
queen here
on c4 and now you can see the queen
is cutting off this square here on a 2
for the king this king can't come to b2
and b1 because of the king here
and so this is stalemate so while
white has the upper hand and material by
a long shot
black has forced white to put himself in
a position where
it's a tie game so you don't want to do
this so the optimal move
after we see that rook
2 d4 is actually an under
promotion and that is to play the pawn
to c8
and promote to a rook now you don't
always see
under promotions working out but
sometimes you always have to think about
a few moves further down the path
and see what your opponent can do and
black already knows that the pawn is
going to promote
and so they're usually thinking about
how can i still get a draw out of this
where white should be thinking about
not how do i just immediately get the
queen but how can i win this game
what can go wrong so that i don't win
this game and if you go to a queen
they can force you by putting your queen
here on c4
into a draw now how does black continue
if
white has his rook here on c8 because
the threat from white is to play rook
2 a8 just the normal rook to c4 is not
going to work here because after the
rook takes
this rook is not attacking that square
here
on a2 so the king can freely come to a2
where before it was attacked by the
queen so this is going to be an easy win
for white because then they could just
play rook to a4
and that's going to be checkmate so if
we come back
understanding the threat that white has
of just coming over here to a8
the only real option that black has
is to play rook to a4 trying to stop
that threat
but then after king 2 b3
this pretty much puts a stop to all the
options that black has
because now the threat of rook to c1
is too much for black to deal with now
yes
black can just play king to b1
protecting the square here
but then you can see the rook here on a4
is going to fall and eventually with a
king
and a rook versus the king white is
going to win the game there's no other
option that black has
to try to hold on to this this is going
to be
checkmate so this all started early on
from this position
and then we start to see the best moves
from white aren't always
the most aggressive attacking lines of
getting it here
with pawn to c7 and then rook to d6 a
lot of players
again they want to attack attack king to
c5 not necessarily the best way
to continue in this position marching
down this b
file making sure it's not on the same
file as the pawn
and then delivering the decisive tactic
is the way
for white to win this so hopefully that
helped you as you have your own endgames
to think about where you should be going
and how your opponent can actually
respond and potentially take away a win
that you have
in your hands if you enjoy this video if
you wouldn't mind
please hitting that like button and let
me know in the comments below
lately i've been doing a lot of unique
chess openings that i know you enjoy
i have a lot of in-game tactics as well
as middle game strategies to go over
but really just want to make content
that you enjoy so if you enjoyed this
particular video and you want to see
other videos like it
please let me know and definitely hit
that like button but thank you guys so
much for watching the video and
supporting the channel
and i'll see you in the next video
you